taraji P Henson caused a stir during the  Super Bowl with this post the actress  said maroon 5 is life as Coldplay was  performing et was on hand and got taraji  - well explained you said on a hilarious  tweet maroon 5 that's like all right so  I don't know how if you know how it goes  down in the sweet little web of drinks  in their kool-aid  lemonade I see I mixed it all and I sat  there and I'm sitting with people who  drank the kool-aid as well so you know  you're doing a tweet I'm kind of like  talking everybody's talking and I'm over  old five and I put it down I was like  that's never a wrong side right no  that's my wrong time to go are you sure  and I said everybody's texting me change  your PO change your poem  I think they're mad because I didn't  give homage to Beyonce I'm like the  Beyonce pulse is coming then I realize  it's cool I'm human I make them I made a  mistake you're cute  it happens come on I drank the kool-aid